Anytime I post about being a stay at home mom and how much I enjoy it,
I get comments like this,
usually along the lines of,
your husband's cheating on you.
Probably he's gonna leave you someday.
You know, just really genuine,
kind comments like that.
And I know a lot of people probably have, like,
past trauma and reasons for not wanting to trust anyone.
To project your bad experiences with marriage or with men
onto other people's marriages
is just ridiculous,
and it's not fair.
And I refuse to,
you know, take it seriously.
And I always stop and think, like,
what do these people expect me to do?
I think they expect me to look at my life.
My husband, I have been married almost 10 years.
We got a great thing going.
I trust him, I love him.
I have every reason to do so.
Our kids are thriving,
they're happy,
they're healthy,
and I get to personally oversee the foundation that is their childhood.
Just look at all of that and go.
Now, you know what, honey?
Change of plans.
We are actually going to start spending about $20,000 per child
per year to pay another woman to do what I do,
to spend time watching our kids.
I'm going to forgo those precious years with them
and I'm gonna go get a 9 to 5 office job.
I'm going to set aside all of the money that I make for myself
simply because some Women on TikTok who don't know you,
don't know me.
Uh, they say that you're a bad guy.
Like, a really bad guy.
Since there are other guys out there who are bad
and who have left their families,
I'm just going to assume that you're going to do that.
That's the kind of relationship that we're gonna have.
It's ridiculous.
I'm not doing that.
I think a lot of people think so little of stay at home moms,
of Tribe Wives,
of homemakers,
of Housewives,
whatever you wanna call them,
and they genuinely think that we're stupid.
We know that bad things can happen,
but we also know that the best things in life,
basically anything worth doing in life,
requires risk.
Turns out that no matter how much of a boss babe you are,
no matter how independent you think you are,
no matter how many prenups you sign,
there is risk in marriage.
There is risk in having any kind of deep,
meaningful connection with another human being,
whether it is a partner,
a spouse, a child,
a friend, a family member.
There is no safe way to love another person,
because at any point,
any of those people could just decide they're done with you.
So for us stay at home moms,
for us, you know,
more traditional women,
we acknowledge that there is risk in our lifestyle,
of course,
but we feel that being able to be with our small children in the few
short Years they have of being small
and personally being the ones who lay the foundation
that is their childhood,
is worth whatever kind of scenario you think is gonna happen, right?
It's worth that risk for us.
I think some people spend their entire lives
just waiting for bad things to happen
and just being suspicious of every single person around them.
And that's fine, if that's what you wanna do,
but life is short,
and I do not think that is any way to live.
I refuse to live that way.
I refuse to think that all men are bad,
because some of them are.
I'm raising two sons, and I think that is such a toxic,
gross, bad mentality to have.
No, thank you. And unfortunately,
I think a lot of people who leave these types of comments
would love to see me fail.
They would love to see my husband leave me
and for me and my kids to be on the streets. Right?
They. That would make them so happy,
because then they could look at me and say,
I told you so.
You shouldn't have been so proud to be a mom.
You shouldn't have been so proud to stay at home with your kids.
You should have lived more like me.
And so to those people,
I say, you know,
keep following along,
keep watching my videos and spending time on my content.
Maybe someday your fantasy will come true.
But until then,
I'm Going to be living in the here and the now.
I have today. I'm going to be spending it with my kids.
I'm gonna be taking care of my husband,
I'm going to be at home with them,
and that's that.